[Music]
so what now can I walk you somewhere I'm
saying here upstairs
oh really give me one reason why I
shouldn't do it I'm drawing a blank
what he's on to us first of all you
gotta wait till she gets my pants off
and then you got to give me a chance to
run that's how you get the money never
drop the con die with the lie and why'd
you come up here professional curiosity
and I like boobs yeah I figured it was a
win-win man a nice guy a really long
time I had what I needed and then the
girl walked in your doing something I
want in yo can we skip the part where it
leads you to believe there's some
earth-shattering hump in the works
there's no earth-shattering hump in the
works yeah I don't even get thinly
veiled allure I saw my favorite chefs
con you me know why we make so much
money we are retired you see there's a
science to getting people to trust you
do we have a deal yes we have a deal
you know maybe the roof is talking about
this is really fun it's all about
emotion in connection what makes you
think you can trust her there's no room
for heart in this game it'll get you
killed
[Music]
I wouldn't trust him if I were you but I
should trust you you got a problem I am
going to kill you
tell me later I cannot believe you right
you can't believe I lied oh that's so
rich from those what you want to say
because you're always lying me and now
we're dead
at the end of the day this is a game of
focus it's very confusing isn't it
that's what you get when you hire
economy
[Music]
gentlemen ladies what if Superman I
decided to fly down rip off the roof of
the White House
grab the president right out of the Oval
Office who would have stopped him I want
to build a team of some very bad people
who I think can do some good
y'all Joker's must be crazy
[Music]
try to escape you die no boyfriend
you irritate or vex me I'm known to be
quite vexing I'm just full warning you
you die they get caught we throw them
under the bus
[Music]
I love this guy
[Applause]
not good don't forget we're the bad guys
a sweet talk to me all of that chit
chats gonna getcha
[Music]
[Music]
so yeah one who sings dog yeah I want to
see stop I was trying to get you there
no hard feelings right we good whisky
what am i 12 how about you hot stuff
water that's a good idea
[Music]
we will never survive
I have an all I can to protect my family
today
now my fear for my child
[Music]
you are tosser
you may not like we were
have enemies
but you need to go home
your husband's wildness disturbs me
I need you to scream for me look at
terms of he's Tarzan there Jane to come
for you
thousand men down in
more on the way we don't stand a chance
impossible to save the blue Mickey loves
my husband is known
[Music]
[Music]
bless me Father for I have sinned
okay what do you want more money
whatever you want oh that's a very poor
choice of words
Oh mr. Franklin I have an offer I want
you to kill someone for me
black briefcase in a locker that is a
job for mr. Franklin this is massive
no trains till tomorrow
404 growing old store affords an age
away and it's not time that I'm trying
to kill one likewise no really
just any
[Music]
I've set them on one another like
starving rats in a cage and you can
watch through the bars
[Music]
bang I mean for information might be a
filthy lap dogs about dear ones he
always is read pretty much yeah follow
me it's down the rabbit hole
who says mr. ezel a star hey what's
wrong with you I'm in our 24 bloodlust
[Music]
to imminent death
[Music]
come back again soon hands
[Music]
don't bring him
Wow you know what a Harlequin is the
Harlequins role is to serve it's nothing
without a master no one gives two traps
who we are beyond that
the Joker and I broke up I wanted a
fresh start but it turns out I wasn't
the only daemon got them looking for
emancipation
ocular knew this queen she lost me
who are you guys
[Music]
here's the deal Quinn you need me
[Music]
we work together
[Applause]
we should order pizza because
[Applause]
the one they should be scared of not you
not miss PJ
who's having a good time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
psycho chick never call a woman check
I'll accept fraud lady wanted but on
occasion [ __ ] hate for anybody to my
right is bounty law series lead and Jake
Cahill himself Rick Dalton and to my
left is Rick stunt double cliff booth so
Rick explain to the audience exactly
what is a stunt double dutch actors are
required to do a lot of dangerous stuff
and cliff here is meant to help carry
the load is that how you describe your
job cliff what carrying his load right
[Music]
[Music]
my hands are registered as lethal
weapons we get into a fight
I accidentally kill you I go to jail
anybody accidentally kills anybody in a
fight to go to jail it's called
manslaughter
[Music]
[Music]
I've ever seen in my whole life Thank
You Kayla before we move you up I want
to ask you something personal
do you think of our slogan fair and
balanced I'm glad you asked our news
people are fair but our opinions balance
the American conversation women are
everywhere we'll let them play golf and
tennis now hrs on the phone because you
called me a skirt yeah the attitude
off-camera was even worse
you're a man hater learn to get along
with the boys you're sexy but you're too
much work I have a whole list we'll
other women come forward you may have
heard there was a dust-up involving
yours truly a few words on that it was
blood coming out of her eyes blood
coming out of her wherever my god wait
am I gonna be the story no no I'm gonna
be the story Oh nobody stops watching
because of a conflict they stop watching
when there isn't one
I wanna convince you that I belong on
air in mistrials I think I'd be freaking
phenomenal on your network I could pluck
you out and move you to the front of the
line but I need to know that you're
loyal I need you to find a way to prove
it
[Music]
you know why Rogers got that door
blocking his office someone has to speak
up someone has to get matched the
television star gretchen carlson dropped
a major bomb shell today because she's
doing
mr. kill fox news we need everyone on
team watch get it on put it on these are
at the end times you do understand I
have to be above this right you know the
entire country is talking about your
period right now sweetheart
this is an island of safety and truth
ready to go to war oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
I didn't see anyone alive for over a
year
[Music]
gotta be an explanation
it's just crazy this is still here maybe
blessed with this valley it's about
rebuilding how much we're doing eight we
don't go down the church we don't
survive I want things to be good we know
we need time it's okay cuz we got done I
mean you no harm
my name is Caleb anybody that one's
hospitable like y'all are this valence /
you and I did because we have faith
mr. Loomis says you have to turn down
Jeff know what I said
see if you need to figure it out figure
I don't need your help it's really sick
being on my own jealousy doesn't see you
will never threaten
fancy wager so what's your plan
[Music]
once upon a time there was a great war
that brought so much sadness to so many
people hardly anyone could remember what
happiness was like but something
happened that changed all that
[Music]
his name is Christopher Robin but we
generally call him Billy a taste theme
our mill yeah
it helped us to believe in the good
things which one would you like this yes
I'm hungry
good the fun things he's your favorite
I'd have to go for the middle one peg
leg pathway piglet and a world full of
imagination
[Music]
Olive White's in a bit I thought we were
just having fun
we're writing a book and we're having
fun
and then just like it's happy turned on
happiness came pouring out
[Music]
[Music]